Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. below me the hillside was covered with dead and dying and with little clusters where shots still rang out a few desperate wretches taking as many sue with them as they could there were hundreds of figures running riding and some just walking across the slope and they were all indians most of them were hurrying across my front to the struggle still boiling just below the hilltop where Custer's group were dying. There may have been a score of them, I can't tell, standing and lying and sprawling in a disordered mass, the pistols and carbines cracking, while the mounted wave of war bonnets and eagle feathers rode round and through and
感谢您收听《历史余温》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在我下方，山坡上布满了死者和垂死者，还有几处零星的枪声响起，一些绝望的可怜虫正尽可能多地拉上几个苏族人陪葬。山坡上有数百个身影在奔跑、骑马，还有一些只是在行走，他们全是印第安人。他们中的大多数人正匆忙穿过我的前方，赶往山顶下方那场仍在激战的冲突，卡斯特的小队就在那里走向死亡。那里可能有二十来个人，我无法确定，他们以一种杂乱无章的状态站着、躺着、瘫倒着，手枪和卡宾枪声不断，而那波骑着马、戴着战帽和鹰羽的战士正绕着他们，穿过他们，
over them, the clubs and lances rising and falling to the yells of Hoon! Hoon! while Gaul's footmen grappled and stabbed and scalped at close quarters. There was no flag flying, no ring of blue shoulder to shoulder, no buckskin figure with flowing locks and sabre. He was one of the still forms in that crawling melee. No, there was just a great hideous scrimmage of bodies, like a big side maul when the ball's well hidden. That was how the 7th Cavalry ended. Hail, 7th Cavalry. Yes, Custer was dead, and every man who'd been on that slope with him. So Dominic, that is the account of the Battle of the Little Bighorn in 1876, written by Sir Harry Flashman, one of Victorian Britain's most distinguished soldiers,
挥舞着棍棒和长矛，伴随着“胡恩！胡恩！”的呐喊声冲杀而下，高尔（Gaul）的步兵们则在近距离进行肉搏、刺杀和剥头皮。没有旗帜飘扬，没有肩并肩的蓝色防线，没有长发飘飘、手持军刀的鹿皮装束身影。他只是那场混乱厮杀中静止的躯体之一。不，那里只有一场巨大而恐怖的混战，就像球被深深埋在人堆里时的那种大乱斗。第七骑兵团就是这样终结的。向第七骑兵团致敬。是的，卡斯特死了，和他一起在那山坡上的每个人也都死了。所以，多米尼克，这就是1876年小大角战役的经过，由维多利亚时代英国最杰出的军人之一哈里·弗莱什曼（Harry Flashman）所写，
of course the fictional creation of George MacDonald Fraser. And he wrote that in Flashman and the Redskins. Probably not a title that would pass muster these days. No, definitely not. But it describes one of the totemic moments in 19th century history, and particularly in American history. And it's the last great stand of, what do we call them? Harry Flashman calls them the Indians, the plain Indians. The Lakota. The Sioux, the Lakota is what they call themselves. So we will come to the kind of the nomenclature later on in this series. We're going to be looking at the story of Custer,
当然，这是乔治·麦克唐纳·弗雷泽（George MacDonald Fraser）虚构创作的人物。他是在《弗莱什曼与红皮肤》（Flashman and the Redskins）中写下这段话的。这个书名在今天恐怕很难过审。不，绝对过不了。但它描述了19世纪历史上，尤其是美国历史上最具标志性的时刻之一。这是最后一次伟大的抵抗，我们该怎么称呼他们呢？哈里·弗莱什曼称他们为印第安人，平原印第安人。拉科塔人（Lakota）。苏族人（Sioux），拉科塔是他们对自己的称呼。所以我们稍后会在这个系列中讨论命名的问题。我们将要审视卡斯特的故事，
of the Sioux, of the Battle of the Little Bighorn and the tragic aftermath. And this is a topic that both of us are passionately interested in, isn't it? That's a brilliant topic, Tom. So people of our generation will probably remember there was a Lady Bird children's history book called The Battle of the Little Bighorn Custer's Last Stand. And one of the great things about this story is that it is, of course, famous in American historical folklore as the last stand of the 7th Cavalry, surrounded, butchered. But it's also, to some degree, the last stand of the Lakota, isn't it? Yeah, absolutely. It's perceived as being, I suppose, perhaps erroneously, the last stand of an old, centuries-old way of life,
苏族人的故事，小大角战役以及随后的悲剧。这是我们俩都非常感兴趣的话题，不是吗？这是一个精彩的话题，汤姆。我们这一代人可能还记得有一本叫《小大角战役：卡斯特的最后抵抗》的“瓢虫”（Lady Bird）儿童历史书。这个故事最棒的地方之一在于，它在美国历史传说中当然非常出名，作为第七骑兵团的最后抵抗，被包围、被屠杀。但从某种程度上说，这也是拉科塔人的最后抵抗，不是吗？是的，绝对是。我认为，尽管可能有些错误，它被视为一种延续了几个世纪的生活方式的最后抵抗，
at bay, before the forces of modernity. Kind of a last hurrah as well. So, I mean, in the American accounts, traditionally, there's been a great emphasis on the horror of the slaughter and it was terrible. But I always remember a comment made by one of the braves who fought there called White Bull, who said it was a glorious battle. I enjoyed it. And I think that amid all the tragedy and the horror, one of the reasons why this story kind of does resonate maybe with children is that there is the sense that this is what history should be like. Oh, totally. It's painted in kind of primary colours. Totally.
在现代力量面前陷入绝境。也算是一种最后的狂欢。所以，我的意思是，在美国的叙事中，传统上非常强调屠杀的恐怖，那确实很可怕。但我一直记得在那里战斗过的一位勇士“白牛”（White Bull）的评论，他说那是一场光荣的战斗。我很享受。我认为在所有的悲剧和恐怖之中，这个故事之所以能引起孩子们的共鸣，原因之一就是人们觉得历史就该是这个样子的。哦，完全正确。它被涂上了某种原色。完全是。
It's drama, dash, people on horses. Yeah. All that kind of thing. Yeah. It is pure swashbuckling history. But it also has a kind of, like all great stories, it has a deeper political and historical resonance because, of course, the news of Custer's defeat at the Little Bighorn on the Great Plains, that reaches the East Coast in the week that the United States is celebrating its centennial.
那是戏剧，是冲锋，是骑马的人。是的。所有那类东西。是的。这纯粹是那种充满冒险色彩的历史。但它也有一种，像所有伟大的故事一样，更深层的政治和历史共鸣，因为当然，卡斯特在大平原小大角战败的消息，传到东海岸时，正值美国庆祝建国一百周年。
Yeah. So we're in 1876. And the story ends up being seen as a kind of the last romantic, but also tragic relic of a vanishing age that the United States is poised in this transition point. You know, the frontier is closing. Capitalism, modernity are carrying all before them. And this is one last moment of the old world, you know, of flowing locks and tomahawks rising and falling and swords and sabres and all that stuff. So you say flowing locks. Harry Flashman
是的。所以我们是在1876年。这个故事最终被视为一个正在消失的时代的最后浪漫，但也是悲剧性的遗迹，美国正处于这个转折点。你知道，边疆正在关闭。资本主义、现代性正在横扫一切。这是旧世界的最后一个瞬间，你知道，长发飘飘，战斧起落，刀剑齐鸣，诸如此类。所以你说长发飘飘。哈里·弗莱什曼
refers to Custer having flowing locks and he refers to how the 7th Cavalry are wearing blue jackets. I mean, actually, neither of those things are true. No. Custer has shorn his locks off at this battle. The 7th Cavalry are not wearing their blue jackets in this battle. And so the sense of the myth against the slightly more dusty reality is, of course, I mean, that's always what happens in history. But I think it's particularly strong with this. And the process of mythologisation, I mean, as you say, the fact that the news reaches the East Coast on the very day when they're celebrating the centenary of the United States itself. I mean, it's incredible. But also the stories are being pumped out very, very fast. The first biography of Custer, A Complete Life of General Custer by Frederick Whittaker,
提到卡斯特留着长发，还提到第七骑兵团穿着蓝色夹克。我的意思是，实际上，这两件事都不是真的。不。卡斯特在这场战斗中剪掉了他的长发。第七骑兵团在这场战斗中并没有穿他们的蓝色夹克。所以，神话与稍微有些尘封的现实之间的这种感觉，当然，我的意思是，历史总是这样。但我认为这在这一事件中尤为强烈。关于神话化的过程，我的意思是，正如你所说，消息传到东海岸的那一天，正是美国庆祝建国一百周年的日子。我的意思是，这太不可思议了。而且故事被非常、非常迅速地炮制出来。卡斯特的第一部传记，弗雷德里克·惠特克（Frederick Whittaker）所著的《卡斯特将军全传》，
which is published that same December in 1876. And it sums up the way in which he will be commemorated in the United States for decades to come. To Custer alone was it given to join a romantic life of perfect success to a death of perfect heroism, to unite the splendors of Austerlitz and Thermopylae, to charge like Murat, to die like Leonidas. Wow. Yeah. But that's a perspective that isn't entirely current today in the United States. No, no, I don't think it is. And maybe we'll come on to discussing how Custer is now seen as, or in the last 50 years or so, has been transformed from a heroic figure to a sort of embodiment of what people see as the ills of American expansion.
于1876年那个十二月出版。它总结了他在未来几十年里将如何被美国所纪念的方式。只有卡斯特，才得以将浪漫的成功人生与完美的英雄之死结合在一起，将奥斯特里茨和温泉关的辉煌融为一体，像缪拉（Murat）一样冲锋，像列奥尼达（Leonidas）一样死去。哇。是的。但这种观点在今天的美国并不完全流行。不，不，我不认为它是。也许我们稍后会讨论卡斯特现在是如何被看待的，或者在过去50年左右的时间里，他已经从一个英雄人物转变为人们眼中美国扩张弊端的化身。
And actually, the reality, I think, is a little bit more complicated. So this story, I guess that the story has three elements, which we'll go into. It's a fantastic subject for The Rest is History, actually, because we were able to follow so many threads. So one of them, obviously, is the story of the Lakota. And indeed, the indigenous people of North America, more generally, the kind of Plains Indians, as they were called at the time, and what happens to them. Because, Dominic, would you say that, I mean, one of the many fascinations of this story is that just as you have Custer on the one side, you have Crazy Horse on the other.
实际上，我认为现实要复杂一些。所以这个故事，我想这个故事有三个要素，我们将深入探讨。这实际上是《历史余温》的一个绝佳主题，因为我们能够追踪到这么多线索。其中之一，显然是拉科塔人的故事。事实上，更广泛地说是北美原住民，也就是当时所谓的“平原印第安人”，以及他们身上发生的事情。因为，多米尼克，你会说，我的意思是，这个故事的许多迷人之处之一在于，正如你有一边的卡斯特，你也有另一边的疯马（Crazy Horse）。
Yeah, and Sitting Bull. And the parallels between their lives in particular are so intriguing. Absolutely. And in a sense, as Custer's reputation has gone down, Crazy Horse's has gone up. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, there's a huge Crazy Horse memorial
是的，还有坐牛（Sitting Bull）。他们生活之间的平行之处特别引人入胜。绝对是。从某种意义上说，随着卡斯特声誉的下降，疯马的声誉却在上升。是的，绝对是。我的意思是，有一个巨大的疯马纪念碑
near Mount Rushmore. Yeah, being built, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. And I think that's what makes it so satisfying a story. Actually, more satisfying even than I was thinking about comparisons with British Imperial stories like Rourke's Drift or The Retreat from Kabul or The Death of General Gordon. What arguably makes it even more satisfying as an adventure story is that you have great
在拉什莫尔山附近。是的，正在建造，对吧？是的。是的，我认为这就是让它成为一个如此令人满意的故事的原因。实际上，甚至比我考虑与英国帝国故事（如罗克渡口之战、喀布尔撤退或戈登将军之死）的比较还要令人满意。可以说，让它作为冒险故事更令人满意的是，你有伟大的
protagonists on both sides. So we'll come to Sitting Bull and Crazy Horse. It's also a story sort of about deep historical forces, about the advance of American modernity, American capitalism, and so on. And it's about one particular man, which is Custer. Custer is a great character. He is a little bit like some of these characters we've talked about. Napoleon, General Gordon, you know, people who are suffused with a kind of egotism
双方的主角。所以我们将谈到坐牛和疯马。这也是一个关于深刻历史力量的故事，关于美国现代性、美国资本主义等的推进。它也是关于一个特定的人，那就是卡斯特。卡斯特是一个伟大的人物。他有点像我们谈论过的一些人物。拿破仑、戈登将军，你知道，那些充满了一种自我主义
and a drive that propels them into the front pages of the newspapers and into the history books where other, maybe more talented people have sort of fallen by the wayside. I mean, Dominic, I have to say that, I mean, one of the characteristics of Custer, and I'm interested to see whether this will stand up to putting him under the microscope, is that there is about him a sense of fun he seems to have enjoyed himself yes and whether that's a mythological creation or or not will be interesting to explore it is interesting i think it's fair to say right at the beginning one of the things about custer custer is a prankster we haven't done many sort of pranksters japester he's an absolute japester as we will, as we will discover. So there's tons of elements. I love stories like this,
和驱动力的人，这使他们登上了报纸的头版和历史书，而其他可能更有才华的人却被淘汰了。我的意思是，多米尼克，我必须说，我的意思是，卡斯特的特征之一，我很想看看这是否经得起显微镜下的审视，那就是他身上有一种乐趣感，他似乎很享受自己，是的，无论这是神话创作还是其他，探索起来都会很有趣。这很有趣，我认为在最开始说清楚这一点是公平的，关于卡斯特的一点是，卡斯特是个恶作剧者，我们没有做过很多关于恶作剧者、小丑的节目，他绝对是个小丑，正如我们将要发现的那样。所以有很多元素。我喜欢这样的故事，
where you take one event and then you start to unpack it. There's the politics of reconstruction. There's the importance of the American Civil War. There's railroads. There's the mass media. There are all of these kinds of things.
你拿出一个事件，然后开始拆解它。有重建时期的政治。有美国内战的重要性。有铁路。有大众媒体。有所有这些种类的事情。
And when I was reading about it, I was thinking how much, weirdly, this series is like a bridge between two completely unconnected Restors History series. Yeah. So on the one hand, last year, we did Columbus, and then we did Cortez and the Fall of the Aztecs, another adventure story with people with kind of flowing hair and floppy hats and stuff. So that's European colonialism and the New World. Yeah. colonialism and the new world yeah the other series is actually titanic where we began with
当我读到它时，我在想，奇怪的是，这个系列就像是两个完全不相关的《历史余温》系列之间的桥梁。是的。所以一方面，去年，我们做了哥伦布，然后我们做了科尔特斯和阿兹特克帝国的灭亡，另一个关于留着长发、戴着软帽的人的冒险故事。所以那是欧洲殖民主义和新世界。是的。殖民主义和新世界，是的，另一个系列实际上是泰坦尼克号，我们从
gilded age america with these great conglomerations with this sense of you know the terrifying leviathan of american capitalism and wall street and modernity and actually custer is the bridge between those two stories because he's kind of inhabiting two worlds, I think. And I think that makes him a really fascinating character because he's trying to be part of the Titanic world, the world of Wall Street and big business and all of this, as we will see. But the public and the press want him to be a kind of American Cortez, an adventurer, a swashbuckuckler a kind of a lone figure battling on the plains all of that sort of stuff so i guess we should start with custer himself shouldn't we yeah let's do that so custer is a he's often seen as this sort of romantic figure this sort of medieval people
镀金时代的美国开始，有着这些巨大的企业集团，有着这种你知道的，美国资本主义、华尔街和现代性的可怕利维坦的感觉，实际上卡斯特是这两个故事之间的桥梁，因为他有点生活在两个世界里，我想。我认为这使他成为一个非常迷人的人物，因为他试图成为泰坦尼克号世界的一部分，华尔街和大型企业以及所有这些的世界，正如我们将要看到的。但公众和媒体希望他成为一种美国的科尔特斯，一个冒险家，一个剑客，一个在平原上战斗的孤独身影，所有那类东西。所以我想我们应该从卡斯特本人开始，不是吗？是的，让我们这样做。所以卡斯特是一个，他经常被视为这种浪漫的人物，这种中世纪的人
call him a gallant knight a medieval relic all of this kind of stuff. One of his great biographers, T.J. Stiles, who wrote a Pulitzer Prize winning book, said, he seemed to represent the country's youth as it slipped away. The nation as it had been and never would be again. He was the exaggerated American. Because that language of knights, knights errant. Yes. Cavaliers. So another brilliant biographer of Custer, Evan S. Connell, in his book, Son of the Morning Star, describes him as this dashing cavalier embedded like a fossil in American folklore. Yeah. I thought you'd like that. But I mean, that's what's said about the Confederacy.
称他为勇敢的骑士，中世纪的遗迹，所有这类东西。他的一位伟大的传记作者，T.J.斯泰尔斯（T.J. Stiles），写了一本获得普利策奖的书，他说，他似乎代表了国家正在消逝的青春。那个曾经存在且永远不会再有的国家。他是被夸大的美国人。因为那种骑士、游侠的语言。是的。骑士。所以卡斯特的另一位杰出传记作者，埃文·S·康奈尔（Evan S. Connell），在他的书《晨星之子》（Son of the Morning Star）中，将他描述为嵌入美国民间传说中像化石一样的潇洒骑士。是的。我想你会喜欢那个的。但我的意思是，这就是关于邦联所说的。
Exactly. Yeah. And Custer is fighting for the Union. Yes. So there is a sense in which he, despite being on the winning side in the Civil War, he is kind of bundled up into that sense of... to people like Jeb Stuart, the knight errant of the Confederacy. The Confederacy saw themselves as living in a Walter Scott world of Arthurian knights. The same will come to be true of the way that, say, Crazy Horse is cast. Yes. Again, as the last of a romantic breed of noble warrior. Totally. Totally, Tom. Yes, exactly. That's what makes the antagonism between them, you know.
完全正确。是的。而卡斯特是在为联邦而战。是的。所以从某种意义上说，尽管他在内战中站在胜利的一方，但他被包裹在那种……对像杰布·斯图尔特（Jeb Stuart）那样的人，邦联的游侠骑士。邦联人认为自己生活在沃尔特·司各特（Walter Scott）的亚瑟王骑士世界中。同样的情况也适用于，比如说，疯马被塑造的方式。是的。再次，作为高贵战士这一浪漫品种的最后一人。完全，完全，汤姆。是的，完全正确。这就是让它们之间的对抗，你知道，
So resonant. So richly symbolic. So satisfying. So Custer, if he is in the kind of exaggerated American, as TJ Styles calls him, it's fitting that he's born in the middle of America, in the middle of nowhere, really. He's born in a place called New Rumley, Ohio. His dad, Tom. Did he have a beard? He did. Of course, he's very satisfying he had a beard his father is called Emmanuel
如此引起共鸣。如此富有象征意义。如此令人满意。所以卡斯特，如果他是那种被夸大的美国人，正如T.J.斯泰尔斯所称的那样，他出生在美国中部，在真正荒凉的地方，这很合适。他出生在一个叫新鲁姆利（New Rumley）的地方，俄亥俄州。他的父亲，汤姆。他有胡子吗？他有。当然，这很令人满意，他有胡子，他的父亲叫伊曼纽尔（Emmanuel），
he's a blacksmith he's a passionate Jacksonian democrat so small government kind of independent yeoman farmers super patriotic very populist
他是个铁匠，他是个热情的杰克逊民主党人，所以是小政府那种独立的自耕农，超级爱国，非常民粹，
you know in the spirit of Andrew Jackson doesn't like you know interfering federal government all of that kind of stuff and Custer imbibes
你知道，秉承安德鲁·杰克逊的精神，不喜欢你知道的，干涉性的联邦政府，所有那类东西，而卡斯特吸收了
that completely and it's going to be really important in this story because it sets him at odds with some of the people who should have been his natural allies. They're also evangelical Christians. They're Methodists.
这一点，这在这个故事中将非常重要，因为它使他与一些本应是他天然盟友的人产生了分歧。他们也是福音派基督徒。他们是卫理公会教徒。
And his father, although his father himself was a great lover of practical jokes. He's a massive japester, isn't he? Yes. But he's also quite a doorman in other respects. He hates the theatre. And he's always sort of telling his son to think about his soul and stuff like that. So is his beard, Dominic, a 19th century Methodist beard?
而他的父亲，尽管他父亲本人是一个非常喜欢恶作剧的人。他是个十足的恶作剧者，不是吗？是的。但在其他方面他也很古板。他讨厌剧院。他总是告诉他的儿子要考虑他的灵魂之类的事情。那么他的胡子，多米尼克，是19世纪卫理公会教徒的胡子吗？
Totally is, Tom. Okay. It's an Ohio Methodist beard. So the listeners can imagine that. Yeah. I don't approve of such a beard, but there you go. He wants his son, George Armstrong, Orty, they call him. They often call him Armstrong.
完全是，汤姆。好的。这是俄亥俄州卫理公会教徒的胡子。所以听众可以想象一下。是的。我不赞成留那样的胡子，但事实就是这样。他希望他的儿子，乔治·阿姆斯特朗（George Armstrong），奥蒂（Orty），他们这样叫他。他们经常叫他阿姆斯特朗。
Custon, who was a little boy, couldn't pronounce Armstrong. He said Orty, and they call him Orty or Armstrong for the rest of his life. They initially wanted him to be an apprentice to a furniture maker. That didn't work out. Custer was obviously rubbish at lathes or whatever. He goes to live with his sister in Monroe, Michigan, which is just south of Detroit, I think. And that becomes a kind of second home to him and is important later on because it's where he'll meet his wife. Yeah, when he's there, he starts doing odd jobs, doesn't he,
卡斯特，小时候发不出阿姆斯特朗的音。他说奥蒂，他们余生都叫他奥蒂或阿姆斯特朗。他们最初想让他当家具制造商的学徒。那没成功。卡斯特显然在车床之类的东西上很烂。他去密歇根州门罗市（Monroe）和他的姐姐住在一起，我想那就在底特律南边。那成了他的第二个家，而且很重要，因为那是他后来遇见他妻子的地方。是的，当他在那里时，他开始做零工，不是吗，
for the town's leading resident. Exactly. Who is a judge. Yes. And this judge, what's he called? Judge Bacon. Yeah. He will be featuring later in the story.
为镇上的主要居民。完全正确。那是一位法官。是的。而这位法官，他叫什么名字？培根法官（Judge Bacon）。是的。他稍后会在故事中出现。
I mean, tremendous name. He will indeed. So Custer ends up, he goes back to Ohio. He becomes a teacher for a little bit. And then at the end of the 1850s, I mean, he's been a completely obscure figure up to this point. He applies to West Point, great military academy at West Point in New York State. And the way that worked was your congressman, every congressman basically had the right to nominate a young man to the military academy. And usually they would nominate a political client because this is a sort of patronage
我的意思是，了不起的名字。他确实会。所以卡斯特最终回到了俄亥俄州。他当了一小会儿老师。然后在19世纪50年代末，我的意思是，到目前为止他一直是一个完全默默无闻的人物。他申请了西点军校，纽约州伟大的西点军校。它的运作方式是你的国会议员，每个国会议员基本上都有权提名一名年轻人进入军校。通常他们会提名一个政治客户，因为这是一个某种赞助
world. And the unusual thing is that Custer is from this very democratic family, but the Republican congressman, it's a new party, the Republican party, an anti-slavery party, the Republican congressman, John Bingham, chooses Custer. And people often wondered why. And basically it seems that it's because of Custer has a habit of interfering with the local girls. Oh, right. Yes. So Bingham has a friend called Alexander Holland. Alexander Holland runs an infirmary, and he has a daughter called Molly. And Custer has started seeing Molly secretly.
的世界。而不寻常的是，卡斯特来自这个非常民主的家庭，但共和党国会议员，这是一个新政党，共和党，一个反奴隶制政党，共和党国会议员约翰·宾厄姆（John Bingham）选择了卡斯特。人们经常想知道为什么。基本上似乎是因为卡斯特有干扰当地女孩的习惯。哦，对了。是的。所以宾厄姆有一个朋友叫亚历山大·霍兰德（Alexander Holland）。亚历山大·霍兰德经营一家医务室，他有一个女儿叫莫莉（Molly）。而卡斯特已经开始秘密地见莫莉了。
We love a poem. The rest is history. Yes, we do. We love a poem, and we love a discreet allusion to yeah lewd banter i think it's lewd banter don't we yes so custer wrote a poem this is sweet i've seen and kissed that crimson lip with honeyed smiles overflowing enchanted watch the opening rose upon my soft cheek flowing i think that's pretty good actually for a teenager i like it it's not bad but also there's a letter surviving letter with a lot of bants about miss lizzie yes and what do we think miss lizzie is and he says uh yeah i've done more with her or rather to her and she to me than any other one not accepting your many days acquaintance with her and if she had a husband he could not have done but one thing
我们喜欢诗。历史余温。是的，我们喜欢。我们喜欢诗，我们也喜欢对，是的，淫秽玩笑的隐晦暗示，我想那是淫秽玩笑，不是吗？是的，所以卡斯特写了一首诗，这很甜，我见过并亲吻过那深红的嘴唇，带着蜂蜜般的微笑溢出，陶醉地看着那朵盛开的玫瑰在我柔软的脸颊上流淌，我想这对一个青少年来说其实相当不错，我喜欢它，这并不坏，但还有一封幸存的信，里面有很多关于莉齐小姐（Miss Lizzie）的玩笑，是的，我们认为莉齐小姐是谁，他说，呃，是的，我和她做的事，或者更确切地说是对她做的事，比她对我做的还要多，比任何其他人都多，不接受你和她相处多日的了解，如果她有一个丈夫，他也不可能做出一件
more than i did and i shall leave you to guess what that was. He says, do you know, I think if I were a congressman, yeah, you'd get rid of such a man. And there was a young lad writing to the daughter of a friend about her, Miss Lizzie. Yeah. I would pack him off to West Point immediately. That's exactly what happens. But there is even at this stage, I think with Custer, a genuine drive, you know, an ambition. He is an ambitious young man. Many of the people we've talked about inging upon manhood, my every thought was ambitious, not to be wealthy, not to be learned, but to be great. And on top of the ambition, maybe one of the reasons why he gets the nomination is actually he's very charming, isn't he?
比我做的事更多的事情。我让你猜那是什么。他说，你知道吗，我想如果我是国会议员，是的，你会摆脱这样一个人。有一个年轻人写信给朋友的女儿关于她，莉齐小姐。是的。我会立刻把他打发到西点军校去。这正是发生的事情。但即使在这个阶段，我认为卡斯特也有真正的动力，你知道，野心。他是一个有野心的年轻人。我们谈论过的许多人，在步入成年时，我的每一个想法都是雄心勃勃的，不是为了富有，不是为了博学，而是为了伟大。而在野心之上，也许他获得提名的原因之一实际上是他非常有魅力，不是吗？
He's very impressive, very dashing. He's fun. Yeah. And I mean, he's very good looking as well. Yeah. He's tall, blonde, blue eyed. There is actually a girl who says he'd make a lovely girl. Yes.
他非常令人印象深刻，非常潇洒。他很有趣。是的。而且我的意思是，他长得也非常好看。是的。他个子高，金发，蓝眼睛。实际上有一个女孩说他会成为一个可爱的女孩。是的。
So fans of gender fluidity. There is that. Yeah. Well, when he gets to West Point, his classmates call him Fanny. Fanny. Yeah. And you can imagine how at a military academy with boys who are competing to be marshal. Yeah. But they also call him cinnamon don't they because he has a hair pomade which smells of cinnamon he does he does and actually his friend tolly mccray said of custer you know he always liked to stand out you know there are insecurities but he doesn't mind being different or looking different no he is the most romantic
所以性别流动性的粉丝们。有那个。是的。好吧，当他到达西点军校时，他的同学叫他范妮（Fanny）。范妮。是的。你可以想象在军校里，男孩们都在竞争成为元帅。是的。但他们也叫他肉桂（Cinnamon），不是吗，因为他有一种闻起来有肉桂味的头发润发油。他确实有，而且实际上他的朋友托利·麦克雷（Tolly McCray）谈到卡斯特时说，你知道，他总是喜欢脱颖而出，你知道，有不安全感，但他不介意与众不同或看起来与众不同，不，他是最浪漫的
of men and delights in something odd. You know, he likes dressing up. Boy, does he like dressing up. He totally likes dressing up. I mean, flamboyant and, dare I say, ludicrous costumes will very much be a theme of this. But also this idea, again, I mean, you know, these parallels,
男人，喜欢一些奇怪的东西。你知道，他喜欢打扮。天哪，他喜欢打扮。他完全喜欢打扮。我的意思是，华丽的，我敢说，荒谬的服装将非常成为这个主题的一部分。但还有这个想法，再次，我的意思是，你知道，这些平行之处，
say, with Crazy Horse and the people he will be fighting, this obsession with hair. Yeah, very true. The coat to wear their hair long. Custer makes a point of wearing his hair long. Yeah. Another of the nicknames he gets at West Point is Curly. Yes. And that is one of the first names that the man who will go on to become Crazy Horse has. Yeah. So it's so resonant, the sense of two extraordinary young men kind of at opposite ends of the country.
比如说，与疯马和他将要战斗的人，这种对头发的痴迷。是的，非常真实。大衣留长发。卡斯特特意留长发。是的。他在西点军校得到的另一个绰号是卷毛（Curly）。是的。而那是那个后来成为疯马的人拥有的第一个名字之一。是的。所以这太引起共鸣了，两个非凡的年轻人分别在国家的两端。
Yes. Kind of doomed to meet. Yeah, I think absolutely. So Custer goes to West Point. You know, there's a definite boarding school aspect to this, isn't there? I mean, they're in dorms. People are being tossed in blankets and things. They're deviling each other and whatever they call it. They're sort of playing all these pranks. Are they stealing apples? Yeah, they totally are doing that. They're sneaking out to the tavern.'re going out to meet girls it's great japes now the great thing for which custer is is notable is he is incredibly badly behaved so one of his classmates said that custer once said to him there are only two points of distinction in the class the head and the foot and he couldn't be the head so he determined that he would support his class as a
是的。注定要相遇。是的，我想绝对是。所以卡斯特去了西点军校。你知道，这肯定有寄宿学校的一面，不是吗？我的意思是，他们在宿舍里。人们被扔在毯子里之类的。他们在折磨彼此，无论他们叫它什么。他们正在玩所有这些恶作剧。他们在偷苹果吗？是的，他们完全在做那个。他们溜出去去酒馆。他们出去见女孩，这真是太棒了。现在，卡斯特值得注意的伟大之处在于，他的行为极其恶劣，所以他的一个同学说，卡斯特曾经对他说，班级里只有两个区别点，头和尾。而他不可能成为头，所以他决定他将支持他的班级作为一个
solid base going to be the worst. And he accumulates in four years one of the worst records in West Point's history, 726 demerits, so black marks. And the adjectives that come up, says TJ Styles again and again in the books are boyish and trifling. Could I read some of the things
坚实的基础，要成为最差的。他在四年里积累了西点军校历史上最糟糕的记录之一，726个扣分，也就是黑点。而T.J.斯泰尔斯在书中反复提到的形容词是幼稚和琐碎。我可以读一些他会做的事情吗
for which he would, I think, give a wonderful sense of him, actually. Do. So calling corporal in a boisterous tone of voice. Yeah. Throwing bread at dinner. Yeah.
我认为这实际上给了他一个很好的感觉。读吧。所以用喧闹的语气叫下士。是的。晚餐时扔面包。是的。
Making boisterous noise in the sink. Boisterous noise. And long hair at inspection. So boisterous seems to be the word. Yeah. So trifling in ranks, marching in from parade. Highly unmilitary and trifling conduct, throwing stones. I mean, he does sound fun.
在水槽里制造喧闹声。喧闹声。还有检查时长发。所以喧闹似乎是那个词。是的。在队伍中琐碎，从阅兵式中行进。高度非军事和琐碎的行为，扔石头。我的意思是，他听起来确实很有趣。
He's very fun. Yeah. Yeah, he's very fun. And people like him. He's got a thirst for attention. He's funny. He plays pranks on the teachers. He sneaks out.
他非常有趣。是的。是的，他非常有趣。人们喜欢他。他渴望关注。他很幽默。他给老师搞恶作剧。他溜出去。
So there's an excellent one about the Spanish class, isn't there? Yes. Where he says, what is class dismissed in Spanish? And so the teacher then says, class dismissed in Spanish. Yeah. And up Custer goes and leads everyone out. Yes. What a brilliant joke that is, Tom.
所以有一个关于西班牙语课的绝佳例子，不是吗？是的。他说，西班牙语中“下课”怎么说？于是老师就用西班牙语说了下课。是的。然后卡斯特就站起来带领大家出去了。是的。那真是个绝妙的笑话，汤姆。
It is a good joke. So he does all this. He's got a high sex drive. He sees a lot of girls, sneaks out to balls and things. He has a great obsession with what he calls the great sleep, which I will allow you to imagine what that is.
那是个好笑话。所以他做了所有这些。他有很高的性欲。他见了很多女孩，溜出去参加舞会之类的。他对他所谓的“伟大的睡眠”有很大的痴迷，我会让你想象那是什么。
He clearly gets gonorrhea at some point at West Point, and this may well have made him infertile because he and his wife have a very active marital life, but no children. And so people have speculated, is this the reason why? The other thing that really occupies him at West Point, I think, is politics, because he has come of age in an era where, you know, the political scene in the United States has become polarized to the point, obviously, of civil war. His father is a Democrat. He is a Democrat. They are quite racist, I think, as a family. People talk again and again about his father's deep antipathy to the Negro, and there's no sense that Custer doesn't share it, that he ever goes against it.
他在西点军校显然在某个时候得了淋病，这很可能使他不育，因为他和他的妻子有非常活跃的婚姻生活，但没有孩子。所以人们推测，这是原因吗？另一件在西点军校真正占据他心头的事情，我认为，是政治，因为他成长在一个时代，你知道，美国的政治舞台已经两极分化到显然是内战的地步。他的父亲是民主党人。他也是民主党人。我认为作为一个家庭，他们相当种族主义。人们反复谈论他父亲对黑人的深深反感，而且没有迹象表明卡斯特不认同这一点，或者他曾经反对过。
He gets on very well with boys from the South. He's in a largely Southern company at West Point. His friends are from Texas, Mississippi, and so on. And we know from his letters that in that run-up to the 1860 presidential election, so that's the election that will bring Abraham Lincoln to power and it will split the country on the issue of slavery. Custer absolutely does not want Lincoln to win. He despises Lincoln and the Republicans.
他和南方的男孩相处得很好。他在西点军校主要在一个南方连队。他的朋友来自德克萨斯、密西西比等等。我们从他的信中知道，在1860年总统大选的准备阶段，也就是将亚伯拉罕·林肯推上权力的选举，它将在奴隶制问题上分裂国家。卡斯特绝对不希望林肯获胜。他鄙视林肯和共和党人。
What's his attitude to slavery? He thinks it's fine. I don't think there's any sense whatsoever that he thinks the South has been introduced. He says Republicans are a sexual interest they are oppressing the south the south has had insult after insult heaped upon her he talks about the john brown yeah moldering in his grave exactly john brown who's a great folk hero to abolitionists but a hate figure to the south after his attempt to sort of launch an insurrection at harper's ferry he says john brown a disgrace. Southern rights have been trampled. They are suffering Northern aggression.
他对奴隶制的态度是什么？他认为这很好。我不认为有任何迹象表明他认为南方被引入了。他说共和党人是一种性利益，他们正在压迫南方，南方受到了侮辱，侮辱堆积在她身上，他谈到约翰·布朗（John Brown），是的，在坟墓里腐烂，正是约翰·布朗，他是废奴主义者心目中的伟大民间英雄，但在他试图在哈珀斯费里发动起义后，他是南方人心目中的仇恨人物，他说约翰·布朗是个耻辱。南方权利被践踏了。他们正在遭受北方的侵略。
He says they reasonably demand that Northern abolitionists shall not interfere with their constitutional rights. So states' rights, all that kind of thing. He's a pure states' rights guy. But actually, interestingly, you get to November 1860, Abraham Lincoln is elected. Lots of Custer's Southern mates say, right, that's it. We're resigning from West Point. We are going home. War is coming. Independent succession is coming, and we want to be part of that.
他说他们合理地要求北方废奴主义者不应干涉他们的宪法权利。所以州权，所有那类东西。他是个纯粹的州权主义者。但实际上，有趣的是，到了1860年11月，亚伯拉罕·林肯当选。卡斯特的许多南方伙伴说，好吧，就是这样。我们要从西点军校辞职。我们要回家了。战争要来了。独立的继承要来了，我们想成为其中的一部分。
Our loyalty is to our state. Custer does not quit. His father is originally from Maryland, which is a kind of border state, and he's grown up in rural Ohio. He, I think, has some sympathy with his Southern classmates, but he is a patriotic American. That's a Rubicon, as it were, Tom, that he will not cross. There is also, isn't there? I mean, I remember later in his career when he's on the planes, he sees, I think, the back of a black woman that is scarred with whip marks. And he says, essentially, you know, that's what we fought the war for.
我们的忠诚属于我们的州。卡斯特没有退出。他的父亲最初来自马里兰州，那是一个某种边境州，他在俄亥俄州农村长大。我认为他对他的一些南方同学有一些同情，但他是一个爱国的美国人。那是一个卢比孔河，汤姆，他不会跨越。还有，不是吗？我的意思是，我记得他职业生涯后期在平原上时，他看到，我想，一个黑人妇女的背部，上面有鞭痕。他说，本质上，你知道，这就是我们为之战斗的战争。
Yeah. To stop that. Yeah. So it's not like he's completely oblivious to the evils of slavery. No, I think the fascinating thing with all this story, Tom, is that everybody is complicated. And that actually, if you tell this whole story of the Battle of the Little Bighorn as a morality tale in which there's goodies and baddies, then you have a problem. Because some of the big baddies, as it were, are precisely the people who fought to demolish white supremacy and led the union cause, like General Sheridan, people who are going to be really... You just used S. Grant.
是的。为了阻止那个。是的。所以并不是说他完全不知道奴隶制的罪恶。不，我认为这个故事中迷人的地方，汤姆，是每个人都很复杂。而且实际上，如果你把小大角战役的整个故事作为一个道德故事来讲述，其中有好人和坏人，那么你就有问题了。因为一些大坏蛋，正如他们所说，恰恰是那些为摧毁白人至上主义而战并领导联邦事业的人，比如谢里登将军（General Sheridan），那些将要真正……你刚才用了S.格兰特（S. Grant）。
People are so important in Custer's story. So everybody, I think it's fair to say, has complicated and often very contradictory views about race and about the future of the United States and all of this kind of business. And Custer is one of them. He's not simple. He's not uncomplicated. The war is coming. He obviously wants to be part of it because And Custer is one of them. He's not simple. He's not uncomplicated. No.
人们在卡斯特的故事中非常重要。所以每个人，我认为公平地说，对种族和美国未来以及所有这类事情都有复杂且往往非常矛盾的观点。而卡斯特就是其中之一。他并不简单。他并不复杂。战争要来了。他显然想成为其中的一部分，因为而卡斯特就是其中之一。他并不简单。他并不复杂。不。
The war is coming. He obviously wants to be part of it because that's what he's trained for. And he has two final japes, which basically come very close to ruling him out. Number one, the final exams, Custer absolutely, as could have been predicted,
战争要来了。他显然想成为其中的一部分，因为那是他受训的目的。他有两个最后的恶作剧，基本上非常接近于让他出局。第一，期末考试，卡斯特绝对，正如可以预料的那样，
breaks into an office. It's real sort of Billy Bunter behavior. He breaks into an office trying to steal the exam of Billy Bunter behavior. He breaks into an office trying to steal the exam paper and copy the exam paper. The instructor finds out, he changes the questions. But doesn't find out that he's taken it, does he? He finds out that the exam has been taken. Yeah, exactly. So he changes the questions. I mean, it's the stuff of like a Harry Potter story or something. He changes all the questions. Loads of them fail. Custer's one of them who fails. And Custer is one of the very few people who is reinstated.
闯入了一个办公室。这真是某种比利·邦特（Billy Bunter）式的行为。他闯入办公室试图偷考试，比利·邦特式的行为。他闯入办公室试图偷试卷并复制试卷。导师发现了，他更改了问题。但没发现他拿走了，对吧？他发现试卷被拿走了。是的，完全正确。所以他更改了问题。我的意思是，这是哈利·波特故事之类的东西。他更改了所有问题。很多人不及格。卡斯特是其中不及格的人之一。而卡斯特是极少数被恢复资格的人之一。
Now, why this is, no one ever knows. Custer is lucky. And he's lucky throughout his career. Maybe he's lucky because he's charming, because he's... I don't know. What do you think, Tom? Yeah, I'm sure that must be part of it. But also, I think that book learning, I mean, you need your book learning, but at the same time, you need a sense of swagger and self-confidence and dash, which Custer clearly has. And I think that it's what we were talking about at the beginning, that people come to admire and even love Custer because they see in him the kind of soldier they would like to be. Yeah, I think you're right. I think even people who know he hasn't done his work and he's breaking all the rules, they can't help but be drawn to him. He's a magnetic personality.
现在，为什么会这样，没人知道。卡斯特很幸运。他在整个职业生涯中都很幸运。也许他很幸运，因为他很有魅力，因为他……我不知道。你怎么看，汤姆？是的，我肯定那一定是其中的一部分。但同时，我认为书本知识，我的意思是，你需要你的书本知识，但与此同时，你需要一种傲慢、自信和冲劲，卡斯特显然拥有这些。我认为这就是我们开始时谈论的，人们开始钦佩甚至爱上卡斯特，因为他们在身上看到了他们想成为的那种士兵。是的，我想你是对的。我想即使是那些知道他没有完成工作并且他打破了所有规则的人，他们也忍不住被他吸引。他是一个有磁性的人格。
Yeah. He'll be on his horse with his long golden curls and it's as though he's leading the charge at Marston Moor or something. It's that kind of quality. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. So he does the final exams in the summer of 1861. The war is now really getting underway. He comes, of course, bottom, 34th out of 34.
是的。他会骑着马，留着长长的金色卷发，就好像他在马斯顿荒原之战（Marston Moor）中带头冲锋一样。就是那种品质。是的，绝对是。绝对是。所以他在1861年夏天参加了期末考试。战争现在真的开始了。他当然排在最后，34人中的第34名。
He has more demerits than he has correct answers. So he has 192 demerits for the year, which is eight short of the limit to be kicked out. But somehow he's scraped through. And then he contrives to shoot himself in the foot because he's doing some supervision of other cadets. Some of them start to have a fight and it's the absolutely, you know,
他的扣分比正确答案还多。所以他这一年有192个扣分，离被开除的限制只差8个。但不知何故他勉强通过了。然后他设法搬起石头砸自己的脚，因为他正在监督其他学员。他们中的一些人开始打架，这是绝对的，你知道，
unbreakable rule that if you're in charge, you break up the fight. Custer says, brilliant, bring it on. Let's have a ring. It's so Tom Brown school days. It's very, you know, fair fight, lads. Yeah. Meet behind the chapel.
铁律，如果你负责，你就得制止打架。卡斯特说，太棒了，来吧。让我们来个擂台。这太像《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》（Tom Brown's School Days）了。这非常，你知道，公平的战斗，小伙子们。是的。在教堂后面见。
And the authorities find out he is charged with neglect of duty and conduct to the prejudice of good order and military discipline. And he has a trial. He has a trial on the 5th of July, 1861. And what is worth noting about this, this has a trial. He has a trial on the 5th of July, 1861. And what is worth noting about this, this is a pattern. This anticipates in a really uncanny way what will happen in the buildup to the Battle of the Little Bighorn. But not just that. I mean, throughout his entire career, isn't it? Yeah. It happens again and again. He has orders. He ignores them. And everyone
当局发现了，他被指控玩忽职守和行为有损良好秩序和军事纪律。他接受了审判。他在1861年7月5日接受了审判。值得注意的是，这接受了审判。他在1861年7月5日接受了审判。值得注意的是，这是一种模式。这以一种非常不可思议的方式预示了小大角战役前夕将要发生的事情。但不仅如此。我的意思是，在他整个职业生涯中，不是吗？是的。它反复发生。他有命令。他无视它们。每个人
says, oh, fine, whatever. And he's actually in real danger. And he begs, just as he does before the Battle of the Little Bighorn. He begs and begs the authorities. He says, listen, there's a great war going on. There's a battle. And I've trained for this. And I want to be part of it to help my friends. And they say, fine. You know, they smile on him.
都说，哦，好吧，随便吧。他实际上处于真正的危险之中。他恳求，就像他在小大角战役前所做的那样。他恳求并恳求当局。他说，听着，有一场伟大的战争正在进行。有一场战斗。我为此受过训练。我想成为其中的一部分来帮助我的朋友。他们说，好吧。你知道，他们对他微笑。
So luck and charm and charisma have saved him. And he is let off. He's given orders to report for duty to Washington, D.C. And as we will see in the second half, the Civil War then changes his life completely. Yeah, it's the making of him. Yeah. Okay, so we will be back after the break and we will look at Custer's Civil War. See you then.
所以运气、魅力和个人魅力拯救了他。他被放过了。他接到命令去华盛顿特区报到。正如我们将在下半部分看到的，内战彻底改变了他的生活。是的，这是他的成就。是的。好的，我们休息后回来，我们将看看卡斯特的内战。到时候见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. Custer's Civil War. See you then. episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in the first of what is going to be a series of episodes on Custer's last stand. And at the moment, we're looking at the early life of Custer. He has just graduated by the skin of his teeth from West Point. And Dominic, I guess because his marks were so bad, he's effectively the most junior officer in the whole unionist army, isn't he? He is. He's absolutely the bottom. He looks dashing. He's blonde.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐余温》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。卡斯特的内战。到时候见。剧集和抢先观看现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余温》。我们正在进行关于卡斯特最后抵抗的系列剧集的第一集。目前，我们正在审视卡斯特的早年生活。他刚刚勉强从西点军校毕业。多米尼克，我想因为他的成绩太差，他实际上是整个联邦军队中最年轻的军官，不是吗？他是。他绝对是垫底的。他看起来很潇洒。他是金发。
He's got his kind of flowing hair and stuff. He's tall. But as you say, he comes with a pretty poor CV. And at first, he's really a glorified messenger boy. He sees the first big battle, the Battle of Bull Run, which is in July 1861, Manassas, as the Confederates call it. That is a crucial battle because it destroys any hope that there'll be a quick end to the war. So the Confederates basically win it, and it ends with Union troops fleeing back to Washington. And after that, so Custer was told to protect this one gun battery. And I think they were almost all wiped out before he could even get out his
他有那种长发飘飘之类的东西。他个子很高。但正如你所说，他带着一份相当糟糕的简历。起初，他真的只是一个美化的传令兵。他看到了第一场大战，1861年7月的布尔河战役（Battle of Bull Run），邦联人称之为马纳萨斯（Manassas）。那是一场关键的战斗，因为它摧毁了战争会迅速结束的任何希望。所以邦联人基本上赢了，它以联邦军队逃回华盛顿而告终。在那之后，卡斯特被告知要保护这个炮兵连。我想在甚至还没来得及拿出他的
gun. And so it's obvious to everybody, God, this is going to be a big deal now. This is going to be a grueling, brutal campaign. But again, that is reminiscent of the, I don't know, sport-loving public school boy going to the front in the First World War. And his brigade being shot all around him before he's even stepped out of the trench. So there's an element of that. But the thing about Custer is he doesn't succumb to it. No. I mean, he remains a kind of blaze of colour. He does. Moving through the grey and blood and smoke and dust. He maintains his sense of colour. He does. Moving through the grey and blood and smoke and dust. He maintains his sense of Dash. He totally does. I think
枪。所以对每个人来说显而易见，天哪，这下事情大条了。这将是一场艰苦、残酷的战役。但话说回来，这让人想起了一战中那些热爱运动、奔赴前线的公立学校男孩。还没走出战壕，他的旅队就在他周围被射杀了。所以这其中有那种成分。但卡斯特的特别之处在于他并没有屈服于此。不。我的意思是，他依然保持着一种光彩夺目。确实。穿行在灰暗、血腥、烟雾和尘土之中。他保持着那种风度。他确实做到了。穿行在灰暗、血腥、烟雾和尘土之中。他保持着那种风度。他完全做到了。我想
he always sees himself, there's always an element of Custer that he sees himself as a character in an adventure story. And he's determined to live out that life as we'll see with his costume later on. So the Union are facing a bigger challenge than they thought. They have to raise effectively a sort of parallel army, a volunteer army as well as their regular army.
他总是把自己看作冒险故事中的一个角色，卡斯特身上总有这种特质。他决心过上那样的生活，正如我们稍后在他的装束中所看到的那样。所以联邦面临的挑战比他们预想的要大。他们实际上必须组建一支平行的军队，一支志愿军，以及他们的正规军。
And a lot of people say, well, we'll serve as officers in the volunteer army, not the regulars, because maybe that'll be a quicker way to promotion. You'll be able to rise more quickly. Custer does that. He volunteers to an infantry brigade of the volunteer army. And his luck, Custer is obsessed with this idea of him being lucky and he falls very very seriously ill we don't know with what this is very common of course in the american
很多人说，好吧，我们去志愿军当军官，不去正规军，因为那可能是晋升的捷径。你能升得更快。卡斯特就是这么做的。他志愿加入志愿军的一个步兵旅。而他的运气——卡斯特痴迷于自己很幸运的想法——他病得非常非常严重，我们不知道是什么病，当然这在美国内战中非常普遍。
civil war i mean disease kills thousands upon thousands of people and customer somehow pulls through even when he was being written off and afterwards he's obsessed with hygiene so it's a very unusual in a swashbuckling hero. Because his wife says that he goes everywhere with a toothbrush, doesn't he? He carries his toothbrush, Tom, into battle with him. He brushes his teeth in battles. He also, she says, is obsessed with washing his hands. So he would do very well in COVID. Yes, he would.
我的意思是，疾病夺去了成千上万人的生命，而卡斯特不知何故挺了过来，即使在他被认为没救的时候。之后他变得非常讲究卫生，这在一位侠客英雄身上非常罕见。因为他妻子说他去哪儿都带着牙刷，不是吗？汤姆，他带着牙刷上战场。他在战斗中刷牙。她说，他还痴迷于洗手。所以他在新冠疫情期间会表现得很好。是的，他会。
He would have impressed people with his hand washing and hand sanitizing routine. And also, the other thing that changes in these early months, which is good for his health, is that he gives up alcohol, doesn't he? Because he's been sent off to recuperate with his sister from his illness. And he gets absolutely blind drunk and kind of crawls home. And from that point on, he never drinks again.
他的洗手和消毒习惯会给人们留下深刻印象。而且，在最初的几个月里，另一件对他健康有益的事情是，他戒酒了，不是吗？因为他被送去和姐姐一起养病。他喝得烂醉如泥，几乎是爬回家的。从那以后，他再也没喝过酒。
Because you would think, Custer's character, he would be a man for a glass or two. Clearly he's up to that point. One of his biographers says of him, he's just drunk on his own self-belief for the rest of his. Yeah. So if he's asked, you know, dinner, do you want a drink? He'll say, I'll have a glass of Alderney, which is an allusion to the cows on Alderney in the Channel Islands, which give very good milk. So he's asking for a glass of milk. Wow. A glass of milk. Yeah. Oh my word. My sister-in-law once went out with an Irishman who only drank milk. I held him in low regard, Tom, I'll be
因为你会觉得，以卡斯特的性格，他应该是个会喝上一两杯的人。显然在那之前他是。他的一位传记作者评价他，说他余生都沉醉在自己的信念中。是的。所以如果有人问他，晚餐要喝点什么吗？他会说，我要一杯奥尔德尼牛奶，这是指海峡群岛奥尔德尼岛上的奶牛，它们产的奶非常好。所以他要的是一杯牛奶。哇。一杯牛奶。是的。天哪。我嫂子曾经和一个只喝牛奶的爱尔兰人约会过。汤姆，我老实说，我对他评价不高。
honest with you. But would you have held Custer in low regard for that? If his prankster side was uppermost. His prankster side is definitely up. That would counterbalance the milk. The other thing that he has to guard against, of course, is gambling. Yeah. He's a great gambler and a stock exchange gambler. His whole life is a series of gambles and he tries to do that. Yeah. I think now that you've asked me this question, I actually think I'd be disconcerted if he was always washing his hands and brushing his teeth in front of me.
但你会因为这个而看轻卡斯特吗？如果他爱搞恶作剧的一面占上风的话。他爱搞恶作剧的一面绝对占上风。那会抵消掉牛奶的影响。当然，他必须防范的另一件事是赌博。是的。他是个大赌徒，还是个股市赌徒。他的一生就是一系列的赌博，他试图这样做。是的。我想既然你问了我这个问题，我其实觉得如果他总是当着我的面洗手和刷牙，我会感到不安。
That would put me off. He brushes his teeth with salt. I mean, that would be very odd, wouldn't it? I'd find that troubling. I don't like any eccentricity in a man, Tom. Anyway, Sir Custer, he starts to rise. He makes a name for himself. He's still very romantic.
那会让我反感。他用盐刷牙。我的意思是，那会很奇怪，不是吗？我会觉得那很困扰。汤姆，我不喜欢男人身上有任何怪癖。总之，卡斯特爵士，他开始崛起。他闯出了名堂。他依然非常浪漫。
And in a war, which is a very unromantic war, in some ways the first industrialized war, a war of mass slaughter, of camps, of disease, he's still – there's a moment in the Peninsula Campaign in 1862. They're digging a mass grave. That tells you what kind Campaign in 1862. They're digging a mass grave. That tells you what kind of war this is. They're digging a mass grave of Union soldiers. Custer sees this one boy, very young boy, and he leans over him and he cuts off a lock of his hair and he takes off the guy's ring and he gives them to a comrade who's come
在一场非常不浪漫的战争中，在某种程度上这是第一次工业化战争，一场大规模屠杀、集中营和疾病的战争，他依然——在1862年的半岛战役中有一个时刻。他们正在挖掘一个万人坑。这告诉你这是一场什么样的战争。他们正在挖掘联邦士兵的万人坑。卡斯特看到了一个男孩，非常年轻的男孩，他俯身剪下他的一缕头发，摘下那个人的戒指，交给了从这个阵亡男孩同一个城镇来的战友。
from the same town as this fallen boy. Yeah. So that's the romantic side, the chivalrous gesture. Exactly. But there is also this slightly Homeric quality that when he's going out to fight, he is like a kind of warrior on the plain of Troy, looking out for individual enemies that he can face. So there's this extraordinary letter that he writes to his sister, Anne, and he describes how he is chasing an officer who's mounted on a real thoroughbred. And he's picked this officer out because he knows it's going to
是的，这就是浪漫的一面，骑士般的举动。没错。但还有一种略带荷马史诗般的特质，当他出去战斗时，他就像特洛伊平原上的一种战士，寻找着他可以面对的个别敌人。所以他写给姐姐安的一封非凡的信中，描述了他如何追逐一名骑着纯种马的军官。他选中了这名军官，因为他知道追逐他会是一场好戏。他直言不讳地说，我选他作为我的猎物。所以这种想法，一方面是骑士精神，但另一方面，他觉得自己是个杀手。汤姆，他喜欢这样。他写信给表弟说，我知道战争很可怕，很多人在死去，他说，但我必须说，我将遗憾看到战争结束。我愿意，是的，很高兴每天都能看到一场战斗。有些人喜欢战争，喜欢那种刺激，那种肾上腺素飙升的感觉。卡斯特就是其中之一。他做些有趣的事。他坐热气球上去。他确实坐了热气球。是的。有个叫撒迪厄斯·洛的人，是气球部队的首席航空官。卡斯特坐上他的飞行器去观察邦联的防线，他真的很喜欢。而且
be good sport to chase him. And he says, overtly, I selected him as my game. So this idea, on the one hand, the chivalry, but on the other hand, the sense that he's a killer. Tom, he loves it. He writes to his cousin. He says, I know the war is terrible and lots of people are dying, he says, but I must say, I shall regret to see the war end. I would be willing, yes, glad to see a battle every day of my life. And there are some people who enjoy wars and who enjoy the thrill, the adrenaline rush. Custer is one of them. He does fun things. He goes up in a balloon. He does go up in a balloon. Yes. There's a guy who's called Taddeus Lowe, the chief aeronaut of the balloon corps. And Custer goes up in his craft to look at the Confederate lines and he really likes it. And
然后他说，好吧，我晚上上去。不幸的是，邦联没有点足够的火，所以他没看清什么。所以他清晨就上去了，不是吗？是的。所以他在他们吃早餐的时候就上去了。他做了所有这些事。他玩得很开心，不是吗？内战中确实有一种奇怪的英勇。所以总有一些战斗暂停的时刻，他会被邀请去参加邦联的婚礼之类的。嗯，因为他在西点军校的很多朋友都在对方阵营。而且，确实有一种骑士般竞争的感觉。所以就在战争快结束时，他的一位朋友，他在西点军校的前室友，
then he says, well, I'll go up at night. Unfortunately, the Confederates haven't lit enough fires, so he doesn't really get any. So he goes up early in the morning, doesn't he? Yeah. So he gets up when they're having their breakfast. He does all these things. He has larks, doesn't he? And there is a sort of weird gallantry sometimes to the Civil War. So there's always moments when there's sort of a pause in the fighting and he'll get invited to kind of Confederate weddings and things. Well, because lots of his friends from West Point are on the other side. And again, there is that sense of a chivalrous rivalry. So right towards the end of the war, there's this friend of his, a former roommate of his at West Point,
托马斯·特克斯·罗瑟。你遇到过他吗？我不知道特克斯·罗瑟。所以他们忙着互相战斗，试图夺取对方的装备、衣柜之类的东西。所以特克斯给卡斯特发了一条信息，亲爱的范妮，我寄给你一条你的衬裤，是我在特里维廉街缴获的。卡斯特回复说，让特克斯指示他的裁缝把燕尾服的下摆做得短一点。后来他写信给伊丽莎白，说他缴获了德克萨斯人的浣熊和松鼠，来自他的私人动物园，他们正在激烈地交战，试图杀死对方，但同时又发生各种涉及浣熊和缴获衣物的恶作剧，是的，这显然是戏剧的一部分，不仅对卡斯特，对邦联那边的人也是如此。
Thomas Tex Rosser. Did you come across him? I don't know about Tex Rosser. So they're busy fighting each other and they're trying to capture each other's kit and wardrobes and things. So Tex sends a message to Custer, dear Fanny, I'm sending you a pair of your drawers, which I captured at Trevelyan Street. And Custer replies, asking Tex to direct his tailor to make the coattails a trifle shorter. And later he writes to Elizabeth saying that he's captured Texas raccoon and squirrel from his private menagerie and they are going hammer and tongs at each other trying to kill each other but at the same time all kinds of japes involving raccoons and captured clothing yes and that is clearly part of of the drama not just for Custer but for people on the confederate
是的，因为当然，这绝不是所有联邦军官的想法。不。有些人更冷酷、更顽强、更具管理意识，但卡斯特决心像马洛里笔下的场景一样去战斗，不是吗？我的意思是，他真的相信这一点。是的。现在，汤姆，你提到了伊丽莎白。我们还没介绍她。当然，我操之过急了。抱歉。是的，1862年。卡斯特引起了联邦指挥官麦克莱伦将军的注意，并作为他的耳目加入了他的参谋部。现在，他开始和许多非常令人印象深刻的人混在一起了。
side as well yeah because of course that's not the way that all Union officers think of it by any means. No. Some are much more sort of grim and dogged and managerial, but Custer is determined to fight this as though it's a scene from Mallory or something, isn't it? I mean, he really believes in that. Yeah. Now, Tom, you mentioned Elizabeth. We haven't introduced her yet. Of course, I was jumping the gun. Sorry. Yeah, 1862. Custer's caught the eye of the Union Commander General McClellan, and he's joined his staff as his kind of eyes and ears. Now, he's now hanging around with lots of very impressive people.
奥尔良的菲利普，是吗？法国王位的觊觎者就在他的参谋部里。所以卡斯特现在进入了一个更高级的世界。他得到了一点假期，去了他姐姐居住的密歇根州门罗市。就在那里，他遇到了伊丽莎白·培根，不是吗？你是伊丽莎白·培根的粉丝吗？他以前见过她，不是吗？当他还是个无名小卒，一个年轻男孩为法官工作的时候。他们举办了一个感恩节派对，这是他给人留下深刻印象的真正时刻，因为他穿着制服，戴着大帽子站在那里，因为他拒绝剪头发。他说，在夺取弗吉尼亚州里士满（邦联首都）之前，我不会剪头发。他在派对上看起来非常英勇，吸引了伊丽莎白的注意。她个子娇小。
Philippe d'Orléans, is it? The pretender to the throne of France is on his staff. So Custer's now moving in a more elevated world. He gets a bit of leave, and he goes to Monroe, Michigan, where his sister lives. And it's there, isn't it, that he meets Elizabeth Bacon. Are you a fan of Elizabeth Bacon? He'd met her before, hadn't he? When he was working for the judge as a nobody, a kind of young boy. They have a Thanksgiving party and this is the real moment when he makes an impression because he's sort of standing there in his uniform and his big hat because he's refusing to cut his hair. He says, I won't cut my hair until we capture Richmond, Virginia, the sort of Confederate capital. And he looks very gallant at this party and he captures Elizabeth's attention. She is sort of small.
她留着棕色头发。她很漂亮，但她非常严肃，不是吗，伊丽莎白？你是伊丽莎白的粉丝吗？莉比？是的，我绝对是伊丽莎白的粉丝。我的意思是，剧透预警，她崇拜卡斯特。是的，而且非常有效地美化了他的传奇。
She's brown haired. She's pretty, but she's very serious, isn't she, Elizabeth? Are you an Elizabeth fan? Libby? Yeah, I'm absolutely an Elizabeth fan. I mean, spoiler alert, she adores Custer. Yeah. And burnishes his legend very, very effectively.
确实。你知道，我喜欢看到美满的婚姻。但法官……不赞成。他不是卡斯特的粉丝。他称他为那个留着胡子的家伙。他说，他已经和镇上的三个女孩睡过了。你为什么要和他有任何瓜葛？我的意思是，他，再次，如果你想到我们谈论的卡斯特的父亲，看起来完全像你所期望的19世纪中叶的美国卫理公会教徒。如果你想象那个时期的严厉法官，他有点秃顶，不是吗？非常坚如磐石，绝不是那种会欣赏一个留长发、搞恶作剧的人。
She does. You know, and I like to see a successful marriage. But the judge... Doesn't approve. Is not a Custer fan. He describes him as that moustached fellow. And he says, he's already slept with three girls from the town. What do you want to have anything to do with him for? I mean, he, again, if you think of, we talked about Custer's father looking absolutely
是的，他绝对不会是那种人的粉丝，他绝不会是那种人的粉丝，尤其是对他心爱的女儿。不，一点也不。所以实际上他们说不。卡斯特被拒绝了。他基本上被送了回去，你知道，看看你能不能做出点名堂来，而实际上他确实做到了。
like you would expect a mid-19th century American Methodist to look like. If you imagine an intimidating judge from the same period, he's kind of very bald isn't he very kind of rock solid very much not the kind of man who would enjoy a man who's allowing his hair to grow out or japes or japes and pranks yeah he wouldn't be a fan of that whatsoever he would not be a fan of that especially not with his beloved daughter no not at all so actually they say no customers were buffed he's basically sent back you know see if you can make something of yourself and actually he does Loved daughter. No, not at all. So actually they say no. Custer is rebuffed. He's basically sent back, you know, see if you can make something of yourself. And actually he does make something of himself because he goes back to the front.
在1863年夏天，他23岁时被提升为准将。就在那时，他真正开始设计自己的服装。我喜欢这个，汤姆。我喜欢设计自己服装的人。我也喜欢。我觉得这非常有纳尔逊或拿破仑的风格。所以他戴着这顶大帽子，不是吗？这是一顶邦联的帽子。
And in the summer of 1863, he is promoted at the age of 23 to Brigadier General. And it's at that point that he really goes to town on designing his own outfit. I love this, Tom. I love somebody who designs his own costume. I love it too. It's very Nelsonian, I think, this, or Napoleonic. So he has this big hat, doesn't he? It's a Confederate hat.
是的，他总是把它戴在一边，像一顶毡帽。嗯，因为他说他皮肤很白，所以他很担心。但正如你所说，他戴着它时带着一种俏皮的角度。是的。你提到了他是如何留长发的，他说在联邦夺取里士满之前他不会剪掉它。
Yeah, which he always wears sort of on one side, like a felt hat. Well, because he says that he has very fair skin, so he's worried about that. But as you say, he wears it at a jaunty angle. Yeah. And you've mentioned how he's growing his hair and he says he won't cut it until he's, you know,
是的。当然，这纯粹是虚荣。完全是。但也相当奇怪，因为他的绰号仍然是范妮。
the union have taken Richmond. Yeah. And of course, this is pure vanity. Totally. But also quite odd because his nickname is still Fanny.
是的。你知道，他留着女孩的发型。是的。但他用这套惊人的军装来衬托它。嗯，他穿着这件黑色天鹅绒夹克。这是轻骑兵夹克，不是吗？
Yeah. You know, he's got a girl's hairstyle. Yeah. But he's setting it off with this sensational military uniform. Well, he's got a girl's hairstyle. Yeah. But he's setting it off with this sensational military uniform. Well, he's got this black velvet jacket. It's a Hussar's jacket, isn't it?
绣着金线，上面有很多金子。是的。金色滚边。在黑色天鹅绒轻骑兵夹克下面，他穿着一件缝着星星的水手衫。我觉得在水手衫上缝星星是一种不寻常的造型。还有一条巨大的红色领巾，巨大的靴子和马刺等等。他的裤子上还有金色的蕾丝。
Embroidered with gold, lots of gold on it. Yeah. Gold piping. And underneath the black sort of velvet Hussar's jacket, he wears a sailor's shirt with stars sewn into it. I think stars sewn into your sailor's shirt is an unusual look. And a huge red cravat and massive boots and spurs and all that. He's got gold lace on his pants.
是的，所有这些东西。问题是，这确实有某种意义，因为如果你是卡斯特那样的指挥官，即那种身先士卒的指挥官，不是在后方策划的人，而是绝对带领部下投入战斗的人，就像纳尔逊那样，你想要脱颖而出。现在，听过特拉法尔加战役那一集的人会记得，纳尔逊在特拉法尔加拒绝换掉他的外套，因为他说，我的部下需要看到我。他们需要看到指挥官。而卡斯特，我认为，也是以同样的方式运作。
Yeah, all of that stuff. And the thing is, there is a sort of sense to this, because if you're the kind of commander that Custer is, i.e. someone who leads from the front, not somebody who's planning at the back, but somebody who is absolutely leading your men into action, as let's say Nelson did, you want to stand out. Now, people who listen to Trafalgar episodes will remember that Nelson refused to change his coat at Trafalgar because he said, my men need to see me. They need to see the commander. And Custer, I think, operates with
他是明星，对吧？他是故事的主角。每个人都需要看着他。我的意思是，你完全可以从军事角度来解释这一点。卡斯特确实从军事角度解释了这一点。他和纳尔逊的区别在于，纳尔逊有权佩戴那些勋章。他是海军军官。卡斯特就像他整个职业生涯中一直做的那样，完全是自由发挥，自己编造一套服装，我确实认为长发、所有的一切，当然，这是为了让战场上的人能看到他，但显然这完全是——我的意思是，他哦，是的，完全是虚荣得惊人。他非常虚荣，他非常虚荣，但他很优秀，我不认为我们应该忽视这一点。我想在他的传记中，TJ·斯泰尔斯说，关于卡斯特写作或讲述他的战争时，遇到的问题之一是他很优秀。他做出了正确的决定。
the same. He is the star, right? He is the hero of the story. Everybody need to see the commander. And Custer, I think, operates with the same. He is the star. He is the hero of the story. Everybody needs to look at him. I mean, you can absolutely make the military case for it. And Custer does make the military case for it. The difference between him and Nelson, Nelson is entitled to wear those medals. He is an officer in the Navy. Custer is going absolutely freelance as he always does throughout his entire career and making up a costume and I do think that that the long hair everything sure it's about enabling people on the battlefield to see him but clearly it's all I mean he's oh yeah totally sensationally vain he's very vain he's very vain but he's good I don't think we should lose sight of that and I think in his biography TJ Stiles says one of the problems with writing about Custer or telling his War, he's good. He makes good decisions.
他激励了他的部下。军队需要明星。而他就是一颗明星。他没有做出错误的判断。他没有输掉战斗。但你能重新表述一下吗？是的。我的意思是，他做出了大胆的决定。
He inspires his men. Armies need stars. And he is a star. And he doesn't make bad calls. He doesn't lose battles. But could you reframe that? Yeah. I mean, he makes bold decisions.
他赌博。而那些赌博得到了回报。是的。我的意思是，难道不可以说，康奈尔在他的书中说，在紧张的情况下，他的反应是即时的且可预测的。他冲锋了。你认为这不公平吗？因为看看那些成就他在内战中声誉的时刻，这似乎并非不真实。而且显然他们得到了回报。是的。所以这很棒。你知道，他成了一名超级巨星。但你可以说，最终，每次你进行赌博，概率上总有某个时刻它不会奏效。
He gambles. And those gambles pay off. Yeah. I mean, would it not be fair to say, so Connell in his book says, in a tight situation, his response was instantaneous and predictable. He charged. Is that unfair, do you think? Because looking at the moments that make his reputation in the Civil War, that seems not untrue. And clearly they pay off. Yeah. So that's brilliant. You know, he becomes a superstar. But you could say that ultimately, every time you take a gamble, the odds are that at some point it's not going to work.
你可以说小大角战役，你知道。你可以。现在，值得一提的是，其他历史学家并没有做出这种判断。所以彼得·考辛斯，他写了一本关于印第安战争的好书，卡斯特凭直觉知道何时冲锋，何时坚守，何时撤退。TJ·斯泰尔斯。他有时猜错了，但更多时候他判断正确，远超大多数人。他在混乱中有一种选择正确路线的天赋。好吧。所以我想，我的意思是，显然这取决于，你知道，你是从小大角战役的角度来看待它，在那里他显然做出了一个非常糟糕的决定，并为此付出了沉重的代价。
And you could say the little bighorn, you know. You could. Now, it's worth saying that other historians don't make that call. So Peter Cousins, who's written a great book on the Indian Wars, Custer knew instinctively when to charge, when to hold fast, and when to retire. TJ Stiles. He sometimes guessed wrong, but more often he judged right far more than most. He had a talent for choosing the correct course amidst chaos. Okay. So I think, I mean, obviously it depends, you know, are you approaching it from the perspective of the little bighorn where clearly he does make a very bad call and pays a heavy price for it.
汤姆，你说得完全对，你不断赌博，总有一天你的运气可能会用完，但也许有一天不会。是的。而且公平地说，卡斯特本人总是否认他很鲁莽。所以他说，我并不轻率或冲动。我对此感到愤慨。我所做的一切都是基于我对可能出现的虚构军事情况的研究结果。我仍然认为有一种轻率的特质。我认为他热爱骑兵冲锋的魅力。他确实热爱。我的意思是，难道不是事实吗，如果你跟随卡斯特进行骑兵冲锋，你比在其他指挥官的部队里更容易死亡？
You're absolutely right, Tom, that you keep gambling and one day your luck may run out, but one day maybe it won't. Yeah. And fair to say that Custer himself always denied that he was kind of rash. So he said, I'm not impetuous or impulsive. I resent that. Everything that I've ever done has been the result of the study that I've made of imaginary military situations that might arise. I still think that there is an impetuous quality. I think that he loves the glamour of a cavalry charge. He does. I mean, is it not the fact that if you're following Custer on a cavalry charge, you are likelier to die than if you're in some other commander's troop?
但你也更有可能获胜，因为卡斯特总是获胜。我的意思是，战争的事情就是你进行赌博。是的，我想也是。作为一名指挥官，你知道你的很多部下会死。所以让我们关注一下这个最著名的例子。美国乃至世界历史上最著名的战役之一，葛底斯堡，内战的关键战役，1863年7月1日、2日和3日。关键时刻，罗伯特·E·李，另一位非常侠客的指挥官，入侵了北方。米德将军正试图找到他。
But you're also more likely to win because Custer always wins. I mean, the thing with war is you make gambles. Yeah, I guess. And as a commander, you know a lot of your men will die. So let's focus in on the most famous example of this. One of the most famous battles in American, if not world history, Gettysburg, the crucial battle of the Civil War, July 1st, 2nd and 3rd, 1863. Crucial moment, Lee, Robert E. Lee, another very swashbuckling commander, has invaded the North. General Meade is trying to find him.
他们终于找到了他，军队的大碰撞。第二天，卡斯特领导了一次冲锋。他的很多部下被杀。卡斯特没有被杀。第三天，关键的第三天，我们在美国内战那一集中谈到过，皮克特冲锋，邦联的最高水位线。邦联看起来好像要击溃联邦军队的时刻，然后，你知道，谁知道会发生什么。
They finally find him, the great clash of the armies. On the second day, Acosta leads a charge. Lots of his men are killed. Acosta isn't killed. And the third day, the crucial third day, we talked about this in our American Civil War episodes, Pickett's charge, the high watermark of the Confederacy. The moment when the Confederacy look as the confederacy the moment when the confederacy look as though they might break the union army and then you know who knows what's going to happen
是卡斯特领导了一次关键的骑兵冲锋，对抗邦联那边的对手，一个叫杰布·斯图尔特的家伙，他是邦联的游侠。是的，你知道，潇洒的帽子，骑士，莱茵河的鲁珀特亲王，所有那些东西。大概卡斯特知道这一点。是的。这对卡斯特来说是一个伟大的时刻。但他正在挑战邦联的骑士。是的。
it's custer who leads a crucial cavalry charge against his opposite number on the confederate side a guy called jeb stewart who is the knight errant of the confederacy yeah you know dashing hat cavalier prince rupertupert the Rhine, all that sort of stuff. And presumably Custer knows that. Yeah. It's a great moment for Custer. But he's taking on the chevalier of the Confederacy. Yeah.
你不觉得那会让他更下定决心去挑战他吗？确实。而这正是你想要的。但你并不总是想要它。我只是这么说。但在这种情况下，你绝对想要它。好吧。我觉得这很苛刻。如果卡斯特没有死在小大角，没人会说这个，你知道，卡斯特，不可靠，你知道，总有一天他的运气会用完。但如果你看看他在这之后和这之前整个职业生涯，卡斯特总是违抗命令。他总是随心所欲。你知道，你可以说他有出色的直觉。他有杀手的本能。他在一个没那么自信的指挥官不会冲锋的地方冲锋，这很棒。但我确实
Don't you think that would make him even more determined to have a crack at him? It does. And that's what you want. But you don't always want it. That's all I'm saying. But you absolutely want it in this context though. Okay. I think it's harsh. If Custer hadn't died a little bighorn, no one would say of this, you know, Custer, dodgy, you know, one day his luck will run out. But if you look at his entire career after this and before this, Custer is always disobeying orders. He's always going off on his own whim. You know, and you can say he has a brilliant instinct. He has the killer instinct. He charges in where a less self-confident commander wouldn't, and that's brilliant. But I do
认为这留下了在某个时刻会出错的可能性。当然，汤姆，确实如此。我完全接受你的观点。但我认为一支获胜的军队需要这样的人，他们会在人们犹豫不决的关键时刻挺身而出。顺便说一句，这是最令人惊叹的场景，第一弗吉尼亚骑兵正在向联邦军队冲锋，卡斯特骑在马上，有些人说他摘下帽子向一些人挥手，有些人说他拿着剑，他大喊，我的意思是，对密歇根的人，他向他们大喊，来吧，你们这些狼獾人，然后他们就冲进了战斗，他们冲锋了一次，是的，他们击退了邦联军。邦联军在韦德·汉普顿的带领下再次进攻，
think it leaves open the possibility that at some point it's going to go wrong. Sure, it does, Tom. It does. I totally take your point. But I think a winning army needs people like this, who will stand up at the crucial moment when people are hesitating it's the most amazing scene by the way the first virginia cavalry are charging at the union troops custer he's on his horse some people say he takes his hat off and waves at some people who have his sword and he shouts i mean the men in michigan he shouts to them come on you wolverines and then off they go into battle they charge once yeah they knock the Confederates back. The Confederates come again under a guy called Wade Hampton,
他后来成了南卡罗来纳州的州长，但那是题外话。而且，他们现在在人数上处于绝对劣势。卡斯特再次下令全速冲锋。再次，来吧，你们这些狼獾人。联邦骑兵，这是斯泰尔斯的书里的内容，咆哮着，把马撞进叛军的队伍里，砍杀所有触手可及的人。
who ends up being governor of South Carolina much later, but that's by the by. And again, they're massively outnumbered now. And again, Custer, again, he orders a full gallop. Again, come on you Wolverines. The Union troopers, this is from Stiles' book, roared and smashed their horses into the rebel ranks, sabering all who came within reach.
军刀的碰撞声充斥着空气。卡斯特在中心战斗。所有这些东西。卡斯特的马被射中倒下。他跳上另一匹马。是的，他最喜欢的马，不是吗？是的。罗阿诺克，是的。
The clashing of sabres filled the air. Custer fought in the centre. All of this sort of stuff. Custer's horse is shot from under him. He jumps on another horse. Yeah, his favourite horse, isn't it? Yeah. Roanoke, yeah.
他跳上另一匹马。是的。真是不可思议。此后，他成了联邦报纸的绝对超级巨星，留着金色长发的男孩将军。还有帽子和剑。因为他喜欢剑，不是吗？他喜欢所有这些。在空中挥舞着他的剑，头发。北方的报纸，他们都在报道他。有趣的是，他的士兵们并没有说卡斯特鲁莽。我觉得和卡斯特在一起不安全。他们说他很出色。
He jumps on another horse. Yeah. It's incredible stuff. He is an absolute superstar after this for the union newspapers, the boy general with the golden locks. And the hat and the sword. Because he loves a sword, doesn't he? He loves all that. Waving his sword in the air, the hair. The newspapers in the North, they're all over him. And interestingly, his soldiers don't say Custer is reckless. I feel unsafe with Custer. They say he's brilliant.
他们谈论他，汤姆，就像纳尔逊的水手谈论纳尔逊一样。我从未见过如此勇敢的人，既能干又勇敢。在他手下，一个人会为胆怯而感到羞耻。在他手下，我们的部下可以创造奇迹。但我的意思是，多米尼克，只是说会有和他一起服役的军官对他有非常不同的看法，他们确实认为他很鲁莽。我认为讨厌他的人，总的来说。卡斯特是一个确实会树敌的人。最著名的一个是我们以后几集会经常谈到的家伙，叫本廷少校，对吧？还有雷诺少校，他也会在战斗中出现一点。
They talk about him, Tom, like Nelson Saylors talk about Nelson. So brave a man I never saw, as competent as brave. Under him, a man is ashamed to be cowardly. Under him, our men can achieve wonders. But I mean, again, Dominic, just to say that there will be officers who serve with him who do have a very different take on him, who do think that he's reckless. People who hate him, I think by and large. Custer is somebody who does make enemies. The most famous one is a guy who we'll be talking about a lot in later episodes called Major Bentine, right? Also Major Reno, who also will feature in the battle a little bit.
所以不幸的是，正是那些在关键时刻卡斯特的生命所依赖的人。但我认为没有任何理由可以削弱他在内战中的成就。他相当合理地是联邦战线上的明星。不，我不是在争论这一点，我只是说，使他在内战中成功的东西，最终也会摧毁他。这就是为什么他成为某种悲剧英雄，我想。你知道，你被你自己的美德所摧毁，不是吗？你自己的品质。这是一场希腊悲剧，汤姆。确实是。就是这样。就是这样。所以总之，他是个大明星。法官让步了。
So unfortunately, the very men on whom Custer's life depends in the crucial hours. But I don't think there's any way of reasonably undermining his achievement in the Civil War. He is quite reasonably the star of the Union lines. No, I'm not disputing that, but I'm just saying that what enables him to be successful in the Civil War is also what will end up destroying him. And that's what makes him a kind of tragic hero, I guess. You know, you're destroyed by your own virtues, aren't you? Your own qualities. It's a Greek tragedy, Tom. It is. Yeah. That's what it is. That's what it is. So anyway, he's a big star. The judge relents.
是的，你现在可以娶我女儿了。所以他娶了莉比。法官也是共和党人，不是吗？是的，法官是共和党人。非常支持联邦事业，没错。他娶了莉比，他们在纽约度蜜月，我想这
Yeah, you can marry my daughter now. So he marries Libby. The judge is Republican as well, though, isn't he? Yeah, the judge is a Republican. Very into the union cause, exactly. He marries Libby the judge is Republican as well though isn't he yeah the judge is a Republican very into the union cause exactly he marries Libby they have their honeymoon in New York I think which is
值得注意，因为我们总是想到边境上的卡斯特，卡斯特最喜欢的地方是纽约，他想在纽约取得成功，而这将在
worth noting because we always think of Custer on the frontier the place Custer loves most of all is New York he wants to be a success in New York and this will come
以后发挥作用，并在他的故事和小大角战役的故事中非常重要。卡斯特基本上是他试图把自己变成纽约大亨的失败尝试，唐纳德·特朗普，是的，这以灾难告终。他和莉比，他们在蜜月期间过得很棒，他们总是互相写信，
into play later on and be very important in his story and the story of the little big horn Custer's basically his failed attempt to turn himself into a new york tycoon donald trump yeah which ends disastrously he and libby they have a brilliant time on the honeymoon they're always writing each other kind
写一些关于他们做了什么的暗示性信件，而且再次，所有这些都是某种代码，是的，他们完全沉浸其中，他们会一直互相写信。哦，我太想要一个了。如果我今晚和她在一起，我知道我会吻哪里。所有这些事情。有一次，他的信，是在你提到的那场战斗中
of suggestive letters about what they've got up to and again there's all this kind of code words for yeah they're all over that they will they will write to each other all the time. Oh, I do want one so badly. I know where I would kiss somebody if I was with her tonight. All this kind of thing. At one point, his letters, it's at one of that battle that you mentioned
那个家伙缴获了他的衣服，真的在车站。他们的信被缴获了，卡斯特不得不写信给莉比说……我很抱歉。我们将不得不使用更复杂的代码。这太尴尬了。就像有人黑进了
where the guy captures his clothes, really in station. Their letters are captured and Custer has to write to Libby and say... I'm really sorry. We're going to have to use a more intricate code. This is very embarrassing. It's like someone hacking
你的WhatsApp一样。是的。所以他们有一种非常紧张的关系。所以为了总结卡斯特在内战中的表现，1864年，林肯不断地洗牌联邦军队，
into your WhatsApp or something. Yeah. So they have a very charged relationship. So just to tie up Custer in the Civil War, in 1864, Lincoln is constantly kind of shuffling the Union pack
因为他迫切需要找到真正能赢的将军。1864年，他得到了一个新的最高指挥官尤利西斯·S·格兰特。格兰特对卡斯特来说将是一个重要人物。在不陷入格兰特的细节的情况下，这里重要的一点是，他们不可能更不同了。我认为公平地说，卡斯特是过去，
because he's desperate to find generals who will actually win. And in 1864, he gets a new Supreme Commander in Ulysses S. Grant. And Grant is going to be a huge figure for Custer. And without getting too bogged down in Grant, the important thing here is that they could not be more different. And I think it's fair to say that Custer is the past,
或者他是美国及其军队的浪漫形象。而格兰特是未来。格兰特不张扬。他谦虚。他是一个策划者。他在计划战争的方式上极其无情和有条理。他是一个赢家。正如《纽约世界报》所说，没有拿破仑式的展示，没有炫耀，没有演讲，没有多余的虚饰。他那种非英雄式的领导模式，现代领导力，与卡斯特的截然不同，这是工业化领导力，不是吗？工业化，没错，是的，那是正确的方式，是的。作为这种变化的一部分，还有一大批像威廉·谢尔曼这样的人，他在南方领导了焦土政策，他们正在崭露头角，从卡斯特的角度来看，最重要的人是一个叫菲利普·谢里登的家伙。
or he's the kind of romantic image of America and of its army. And Grant is the future. Grant is unostentatious. He's modest. He's a planner. He's utterly ruthless and methodical in the way he plans the war. He's a winner. As the New York world says, no Napoleonic displays, no ostentation, no speech, no superfluous flummery. And his model of unheroic leadership modern leadership could not be more different from Custer's it's industrial leadership isn't it industrial exactly yeah that's the right way yeah and as part of this change and a whole load of new people like William Sherman who leads the scorched earth campaign in the south they're coming to the fore the most important one from from Custer's point of view is a chap called Philip Sheridan.
谢里登将成为格兰特的骑兵指挥官，也就是卡斯特的老板。小菲尔。谢里登非常矮，不是吗？五英尺五英寸。他是爱尔兰裔。他极其凶猛，但他也具有政治激进性。他真的很讨厌邦联。他想摧毁白人至上主义。他最终会成为卡斯特的伟大赞助人。但当然，在政治上，他们有点不合。谢里登和卡斯特在1864年穿过谢南多厄河谷战斗，某种程度上把邦联军赶了回去。威廉·T·谢尔曼将军正穿过佐治亚州向海岸进军，某种程度上蹂躏着土地。一步一步，他们正在
Sheridan is going to be Grant's cavalry commander, so Custer's boss. Little Phil. Sheridan is extremely short, isn't he? Five foot five. He's of Irish extraction. He's incredibly fierce, but he's also politically radical. He really hates the Confederacy. He wants to demolish white supremacy. He will end up being Custer's great patron. But of course, politically, they're slightly at odds. Sheridan and Custer are fighting through the Shenandoah Valley in 1864, kind of driving the Confederates back. General William T. Sherman is marching to the coast through Georgia, sort of ravaging the land. Step by step, they are
挤压邦联。所以我们终于到了1865年。再一次，战争的最后一场大战，水手溪，1865年4月。卡斯特的马又一次被射中倒下。他的兄弟汤姆现在和他在一起，汤姆脸部中弹。他是一个悲剧人物，不是吗？卡斯特有三个兄弟，其中两个最终会死在小大角。所以他有汤姆·卡斯特和他的弟弟波士顿，他实际上不在军队里，但算是供应商。是的。但汤姆·卡斯特非常英勇，不是吗？
squeezing the Confederacy. So finally we get to 1865. Once again, the last great battle of the war, Sailor's Creek, April 1965. Custer's horse yet again is shot from under him. His brother Tom is with him now as Tom gets shot in the cheek. He's a tragic figure, isn't he? Custer has three brothers, two of whom will end up at Bighorn, little Bighorn. So he's got Tom Custer and his younger brother, Boston, who isn't actually in the army, but is kind of a supplier. Yeah. But Tom Custer is incredibly heroic, isn't he?
我的意思是，他因为勇气获得了各种勋章。他确实获得了。汤姆崇拜乔治·阿姆斯特朗·卡斯特，他认为他很出色，卡斯特一家是一个非常紧密的群体，所以我们到了1865年4月9日，阿波马托克斯法院，李的军队，那支庞大的邦联军队现在终于基本上被切断、包围，没有补给，是卡斯特走上前去要求投降。他去见李的副手朗斯特里特将军，说，你知道，你想向我投降吗？
I mean, he gets all kinds of medals for courage. He does. And Tom adores george armstrong custer he thinks he's brilliant and the custers are the very kind of tight-knit group so we get to um the 9th of april 1865 appomattox courthouse lee's army the big confederate army is now finally basically cut off surrounded no supplies it is Custer who goes forward to demand a surrender. And he goes to see Lee's deputy general, Longstreet, and says, you know, do you want to surrender to me?
朗斯特里特显然看着这个留着金色长发的家伙。卡斯特看起来大约10岁，因为他当时才25岁。他说，我永远不会向你投降。我会向格兰特投降，但我不会向你投降。卡斯特最终同意了。但随后有一个非常、非常说明问题的时刻。那天下午四点，李确实向格兰特投降了，这是美国历史上非常著名的时刻。
And Longstreet apparently looks at this bloke with his long, blonde hair. And Custer looks about 10, because he's still only 25. And he says, I will never surrender to you. I'll surrender to Grant, but I won't surrender to you. Custer finally agrees. But there's then a really, really telling moment. So at four o'clock that afternoon, Lee does surrender to Grant, this very famous moment in American history.
当李这样做时，他看到格兰特旁边站着格兰特的军事秘书，一个叫伊莱·帕克的人。伊莱·帕克是美洲原住民。他来自塞内卡部落。所以他来自纽约。李看到了这一点，他对这个家伙说，我很高兴看到这里至少有一个真正的美国人。帕克说，好吧，我们都是美国人。你知道，非常像好莱坞。但问题是，他们是吗？你知道，在这一点上，这是一个未解决的问题。
And when Lee does that, he sees standing next to Grant, Grant's military secretary, who's a guy called Eli Parker. And Eli Parker is a Native American. He's from the Seneca. So he's from New York. And Lee sees this and he says to this guy, I am glad to see that there's at least one real American here. And Parker says, well, we're all Americans. You know, very Hollywood. But the thing is, are they? You know, this is an unresolved question at this point.
当你问他们时，你是说美洲原住民还是邦联军，或者？我故意含糊其辞。对。因为邦联军在这个重新统一的国家未来中处于什么位置？但美洲原住民又将处于什么位置，对吧？美洲原住民又将处于什么位置？因为当然，不仅是塞内卡人，西部还有很多其他人，很多其他民族，对他们来说，内战只是一场插曲。
When you say they, do you mean the Native Americans or the Confederates or? I'm deliberately being ambiguous. Right. Because where do the Confederates sit in the future of this reunited nation? But also where will the Native Americans sit, right? And where will the Native Americans? Because of course, not just the Seneca, but there are a lot of other people, a lot of other nations out there in the West to whom the Civil War has been a sideshow.
他们对内战不感兴趣。在他们看来，他们有更重要的事情要做。所以这一切都在未来。帕克将成为其中的一个非常重要的人物，因为他与尤利西斯·S·格兰特非常亲近，格兰特最终将成为总统，他会带上帕克，让他去解决他所认为的欧洲裔美国人与土著邻居的关系问题，他要一劳永逸地解决这个问题。而该政策的瓦解将对
They're not interested in the Civil War. They have much bigger fish to fry as they see it. So all of this lies in the future. And Parker is going to be a very important figure in this because he's very close to ulysses s grant grant is going to become president eventually and he will bring parker with him and get him to as he sees it settle the question of you know european-born americans relationship with their indigenous neighbors, that he was going to settle this question once and for all. And the unraveling of that policy will have a massive impact on
卡斯特的生活和死亡产生巨大影响。但当然，目前为止，这一切都在未来。战争结束了。谢里登将军买下了格兰特和李签署协议的那张桌子，他把它送给了卡斯特的妻子，不是吗，汤姆？他确实送了，是的。不可思议的事情。是的。他说，请允许我说，夫人，在我们服役的人中，几乎没有人比你那位非常英勇的丈夫对实现这一理想结果贡献更多。
Custer's life and death. But of course, for the time being, all that lies in the future. The war is over. General Sheridan buys the table on which Grant and Lee signed the deal, and he gives it to Custer's wife, doesn't he, Tom? He does, yeah. Incredible thing. Yeah. And he says, permit me to say, madam, there is scarcely an individual in our service who's contributed more to bring about this desirable result than your very gallant husband.
什么？我的意思是，这就是你的答案。谢里登认为卡斯特确实在其中发挥了巨大的作用。他这样做不仅仅是为了对莉比好。他根本不在乎莉比。人们常说，卡斯特之于谢里登，就像缪拉之于拿破仑。是的。谢里登显然对他在卡斯特身上识别出的那种冲劲和英勇做出了回应，并钦佩它。是的。他们需要它。他们需要它。是的。即使是格兰特，他们也需要一张那样的牌来打，而卡斯特就是那张牌。
What? I mean, there is your answer. Sheridan thinks Custer really played a massive role in this. He's not doing that just to be nice to Libby. He doesn't give a damn about Libby. It's often said, isn't it, that Custer is kind of Murat to Sheridan's Napoleon. Yeah. That Sheridan clearly responds to the sense of dash and gallantry that he recognises in Custer and admires it. Yeah. They need it. They need it. Yeah. Even Grant, they need a card like that to play and Custer is that card.
是的。多米尼克，当伊丽莎白·卡斯特在林肯被枪杀前不久会见亚伯拉罕·林肯时，这一点得到了完美的总结。林肯对伊丽莎白·卡斯特说，哦，所以这就是那个丈夫带着欢呼和呐喊冲锋的年轻人的妻子。所以这显然就是他那种欢呼和呐喊的声誉。伊丽莎白·卡斯特对此回答说，是的，我希望他永远这样做。林肯反过来说，我明白了。所以你希望成为一名寡妇。好吧，那真是一次惊人的交流。是的。不祥的。不祥的，汤姆。
Yeah. And Dominic, this is perfectly summed up when Elizabeth Custer meets with Abraham Lincoln shortly before Lincoln gets shot. And Lincoln says to Elizabeth Custer, oh, so this is the young man whose husband goes into a charge with a whoop and a shout. So that's clearly very much his reputation of whoop and a shout. And Elizabeth Custer replies to this, yes, and I hope he will always do so. And Lincoln says, in turn, I see. So you hope to be a widow. Well, that is an amazing exchange. Yeah. Ominous. Ominous, Tom.
TJ·斯泰尔斯在他的传记中以这样的话结束了这一部分，卡斯特当时只有25岁。他拥有军队中第二高的军衔。无视资历，他杀过人，赢过战斗。他是个名人。他的成功教会了他许多关于自己和世界的教训。而他余生都将学习到它们是错误的。哇。
T.J. Stiles in his biography ends this section by saying, Custer was only 25. He held the second highest rank in the army. Disregarding seniority, he'd killed men and won battles. He was a celebrity. His success had taught him many lessons about himself and the world. And he'd spend the rest of his life learning that they were wrong. Wow.
所以这基本上和林肯的评论是一回事，不是吗？你到目前为止所学的一切，都将导致你未来的灾难。下次，我们将把卡斯特带到边境，我们将看到他如何沉浸在重建的动荡和战后政治的蛇坑中。汤姆，他将第一次与平原印第安人相遇。一个惊人的故事。当然，如果人们现在想听那个，他们能做什么吗？你知道什么吗？
So it's basically the same thing as Lincoln's comments, isn't it? Everything you've learned up till now is what will lead you to disaster in the future. And next time, we'll get Custer to the frontier, and we'll see how he becomes absorbed in the turmoil of reconstruction and the snake pit of post-war politics. And he will have his first encounters, Tom, with the Plains Indians. An amazing story. And of course, if people want to hear that right now, is there anything they can do? Are you aware of anything?
所以这基本上和林肯的评论是一回事，不是吗？你迄今为止所学的一切，都将导致你未来的灾难。下一次，我们将把卡斯特带到边疆，看看他如何被卷入重建的动荡和战后政治的蛇穴之中。汤姆，他将迎来与平原印第安人的首次接触。一个令人惊叹的故事。当然，如果人们现在就想听这个故事，他们能做些什么吗？你知道有什么办法吗？
They can absolutely sign up to the Rest Is History Club at, what is it, therestishistory.com? The Rest Is History, how can you not know? I what is it the rest is history.com the rest is history how can you not know i forgot the rest is history.com at the rest is history.com and dominic if you do that you don't only get immediate access to all the episodes but you also get a host of other benefits don't you so unbelievable unbelievable value yeah truly unbelievable but you don't have to either way we will be carrying on this extraordinary story and we look forward to you joining us very
他们绝对可以注册“历史余韵”俱乐部，网址是什么来着？therestishistory.com？“历史余韵”，你怎么会不知道呢？我……是什么来着？therestishistory.com，“历史余韵”，你怎么会不知道呢？我忘了，therestishistory.com，就在therestishistory.com。多米尼克，如果你这样做，不仅能立即收听所有剧集，还能获得许多其他福利，不是吗？真是难以置信，难以置信的超值。是的，确实难以置信。但你也可以不这样做，无论如何，我们都会继续讲述这个非凡的故事，期待你很快加入我们。
soon bye bye bye bye I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of
再见，再见，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐余韵》。这是你每周的
entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕后，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。